LAURA DECOOK: Hi, everyone.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
My name is Laura DeCook
and I'm a brand specialist
on the YouTube operations team.
I also want to extend a
big welcome to all of you
on the live stream
across the globe.
Last fall, I had the pleasure
of meeting our guest today, Mr.
Don George, at an event
sponsored by adventure travel
company Geographic Expeditions
for the organization Room
to Read.
For those of you who don't
know what Room to Read is,
it partners with
local communities
throughout the developing world
to build libraries and develop
literacy skills among
primary school children.
Now, a little bit
about our guest.
"National Geographic" has called
Don George a legendary travel
writer and editor.
Don has been exploring
new frontiers
as an author, editor, and
adventurer for almost four
decades.
He's also an acclaimed teacher,
speaker, and tour leader,
visiting more than 90
countries on six continents.
Don has published
hundreds of articles
in dozens of magazines and
newspapers around the world.
He's been travel editor at
the "San Francisco Chronicle,"
and global travel editor
for Lonely Planet.
He's the author of "Lonely
Planet's Guide to Travel
Writing," the bestselling travel
writing guide on the planet.
Don currently is editor at
large for "National Geographic
Traveler," special features
editor for BBC Travel,
and editor of Geographic
Expeditions' literary travel
blog.
He has received dozens of awards
for his writing and editing,
including 10 Lowell Thomas
awards from the Society
of American Travel Writers.
He consults globally in
travel and social media
and hosts a national series
of onstage conversations
with other prominent
travel writers.
Don's newest book, "The
Way of Wanderlust-- The
Best Travel Writing
of Don George,"
spans 24 countries
on six continents,
beginning with the 1977 tale
of climbing Mount Kilimanjaro
and ending with the 2015
story about exploring
the jungles of Cambodia,
my personal favorite story.
It is a must read for
any traveler lover
and truly dives deep into
the heart, mind, and soul
of the global wanderer.
Without further ado,
I'm extremely honored
to introduce Mr. Don
George to all of you.
Please give him a warm welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
DON GEORGE: Thank you, Laura.
Hello, everyone.
Thank you so much for coming.
I was hoping maybe five
people would show up,
so I'm kind of blown away right
now to see a room full of you.
Thank you so much for coming.
I want to begin
by thanking Laura
very deeply for inviting
me to speak here
and for coordinating this
event and for spreading
the word so wonderfully.
I want to thank
Google for having
me here and for putting on
this great series of talks--
what a wonderful thing to do.
It's really a great honor
and pleasure to be here today
and to talk to you all.
I'm going to share
my love of travel
and hopefully hear about
your love of travel
and try to give you
some good information
and some inspiration
too, I hope.
I wanted to thank Google
for everything that it does.
I want to thank you
for the great products
that you create,
which I use every day,
which everyone I
know uses every day
and pretty much everyone
around the planet, I think,
almost uses every day.
And truly, you
have done something
to bring the world
closer together, which is
what I think travel does too.
But in your own way, you're
all bringing the world
closer together, and I
really appreciate that.
And the world, I think,
appreciates that, so thank you.
On behalf of the world,
thank you very much.
I've been extremely
fortunate to spend
my entire professional
life doing
two things I love the most,
traveling and writing.
And as Laura mentioned, I
recently published this book.
It's a kind of
culmination of my career
to date, "The Way
of Wanderlust--
The Best Travel
Writing of Don George."
It brings together 35 of
my best stories and essays
from 40 years of world wandering
and 38 years of publishing.
So what I thought
I would do today
is talk briefly about my
career as a travel writer
and the book itself.
I thought I'd read a couple
of pieces from the book,
just to give you a little tiny
sense of what the book is all
about.
And then I thought I would just
open the floor to questions.
So I hope that you've come
prepared with questions,
because I really love
interacting with an audience.
I love hearing why you're
here, or what questions you
brought with you here.
And I think that
that often produces
the best stories and the
best interactions of all.
So I'll tell you a
little bit about my life
as a travel writer, and
we'll go from there.
I didn't start out to
be a travel writer.
I wanted to be a poet, which
is a pretty practical goal.
Poets make a really good
living, I understand.
My parents were thrilled when I
announced that to them one day.
So in high school and
college-- in college
I studied French, English,
and American literature,
and then I minored
in creative writing.
And I would tell people
I wanted to be a poet.
I thought probably a
more practical route
was that I would be a
professor, the tweedy professor,
the kind of professor that I had
grown up with as role models.
Because when you're a student,
those are your role models,
your tweedy professors.
So I thought that's what
I would do with my life.
But I went to Princeton
on the east coast.
And in the spring term
of my senior year,
I just realized I
didn't know what
I wanted to do with my life.
I had no idea, and
I really just wanted
to postpone the decision
as long as I could.
So while my friends
were applying
to medical school and graduate
school and business school
and getting jobs
at banks and having
all kinds of
practical career paths
they were laying the pavement
for, I didn't know what to do.
And I ended up applying to the
Princeton French department
for a summer work
abroad fellowship, which
I got to live in Paris, and I
worked as a translator in Paris
for the summer.
And then I applied
to the Athens college
in Athens, Greece for a one
year Athens college teaching
fellowship.
And I won that, somehow.
And so my year after graduation,
I went to Paris first
and then I went to Athens,
and I spent a year abroad.
And that's when
everything changed.
And I thought I would read a
little bit, just a little bit
from the introduction
to my book about how
things changed for me.
"I took my first
serendipitous step
on the path to becoming
a travel writer
the summer after I
graduated from Princeton.
While all my friends
were preparing
for graduate school, law
school, business school,
or medical school, or
starting jobs with banks,
I arranged to go to
Europe for a year,
first to spend the summer
in Paris on a summer work
abroad internship and then to
teach in Greece on an Athens
college teaching fellowship.
When I set off for
Europe, I was thinking
that year would be
a brief interlude
between undergraduate
and graduate schools.
But then one sun-dappled
June morning in Paris,
the course of my life changed.
As I had every morning for
the previous two weeks,
I took the rickety old filigreed
elevator from my apartment
right on the Rue of Rivoli,
looking onto the Jardin de
Tuileries and stepped into the
street, into a sea of French.
Everyone around me
was speaking French,
wearing French, looking French,
acting French, shrugging
their shoulders and
twirling their scarves
and drinking their cafe creme,
calling out, Bonjour, Monsieur
Don, and paying for "Le Monds"
or "Le Nouvel Observeteur"
francs, and stepping
importantly around me
and staring straight
into my eyes
and suddenly smiling in a
way that only the French do.
Until that time, I had spent
most of my life in classrooms.
And I was planning after
that European detour
to spend most of the rest
of my life in classrooms.
Suddenly, it struck me.
This was the classroom.
Not the musty, shadowed,
ivy-draped buildings
in which I had spent
the previous four years.
This world of wide boulevards
and centuries-old buildings
and six-table sawdust
restaurants and glasses
of vin ordinaire and fire eaters
on street corners and poetry
readings and cramped
second-floor bookshops
and mysterious women who smiled
at me so that my heart leaped.
And I walked for hours
restless under the plane trees
by the Seine.
This was the classroom.
Hungry in a way I'd never been
before, I gorged on Paris.
I marveled at Moliere
at the Comedie-Francaise
and the Ballet
Bejart in the park.
I idled among the
secondhand shelves
at Shakespeare and
Company, eavesdropping
on poets and poseurs.
I immerse myself
in Manet and Monet
and the Musee d'Orsay, got
lost in the ancient alleys
of Montmarche and the Mare,
savored the open-air theater
from a sidewalk seat
on the Champs d'Elysee
and conjured Hemingway
on Rue Descartes
and in Les Deux Magots cafe.
At the end of that summer,
I rode the Orient Express
to Greece and settled on the
campus of Athens College.
As it turned out,
my fellowship duties
were to teach five hours of
literature and writing classes
a week.
I also had to write occasional
speeches for the college
president and write and edit
articles for the school's
quarterly alumni magazine.
This left me uncharted
expanses of free time, which
I exuberantly filled reading
Plato by the Parthenon,
sipping ouzo on
bazouki-brightened nights
in the Plaka, communing with
muses among the red poppies
and wide columns of Corinth, and
exploring the beaches of Rhodes
and the ruins of Crete.
Winter and spring vacations
afforded the time to venture
even farther, and I
wandered footloose
through Italy,
Turkey, and Egypt,
intoxicated with the newness and
possibility of this unfurling
world.
My wanderlust bloomed.
Every moment seemed unbearably
precious, every outing
an exhilarating lesson
in a new culture, place,
and people, full of
thrilling sights and smells,
tastes, and textures, creations
and traditions, encounters
and connections--
a whole new world.
That year changed my life.
And as the end of
the Athens school
approached and the question
of what to do with my life
loomed again, I
found the courage
to relinquish the student
hand me down desire
to become a tweedy
professor and chose instead
the uncharted path
of becoming a writer.
I had no idea where
that path would lead.
I just knew that I wanted to
walk it, wild and wide-eyed,
daring to dream."
That's how I became
a travel writer.
That's the beginning of how
I became a travel writer.
I got a master's degree
in creative writing.
Still didn't know what
to do with my life.
I won a two-year
fellowship from Princeton,
a Princeton in Asia fellowship
to go teach in Japan
at a school called International
Christian University, which
had bilingual, lots of
English language classes.
That's where I'm at my
wonderful wife, Kuniko,
who's in the audience, and
who changed my life again.
And I fell in love
with Japan and started
to write some travel stories.
And when I came back at
the end of that fellowship,
I came back to
the United States,
decided to settle
in San Francisco,
because I'd never thought about
living in San Francisco before,
but it seems like a congenial
and cosmopolitan place.
And I got here and through
a very incredible series
of serendipities that would
require a couple of bottles
of wine for me to really
adequately tell you about,
I ended up getting a job as
a travel writer for the "San
Francisco Examiner," the
"Examiner" and "Chronicle."
And I did that for a year, and
that really changed my life.
I never changed
course after that.
I became a travel writer.
That was in 1980, and I've been
a travel writer and editor ever
since then.
I was at the Examiner
Chronicle for 15 years.
From there, I moved to a startup
at that time called salon.com.
Do you all know Salon?
Yep, a startup.
I was the wanderlust
editor for Salon.
I started the Wanderlust
Travel Site on Salon.
And that was a really heady,
wonderful, exhilarating time
when-- you may be
familiar with this notion,
but we were writing
the rules, basically.
It was the Wild West
of internet publishing.
And we were one of the
first people there,
and we were making it
up as we went along.
And it was really, really fun.
I left Salon after
six years and I
went to work with
my good friends
Tony and Maureen Wheeler
at Lonely Planet.
Does anybody know Lonely Planet?
Amazing, wonderful guidebooks.
They asked me to become the
global travel editor there.
I wrote a column
for their website.
I edited one
literary book a year.
I helped oversee the editorial
direction of Lonely Planet.
And for better or for worse,
I was the public spokesperson
for Lonely Planet.
I was the face of Lonely
Planet for about seven years.
And it was wonderful.
It was a really magical ride
with a great company that
believes strongly in
the power of travel,
the transformational
power of travel
and why we all should
get out and see the world
and share ourselves
with the world.
So I was absolutely in
tune with that message
and loved that job.
In 2007, I decided
to spread my wings
and try life as a freelancer.
And I immediately went to
work both for Geographic
Expeditions, editing their
wonderful website and blog.
And I brought some catalogs
from Geographic Expeditions
around the table there.
They're a really fantastic
adventure travel company
that travels all
around the world
and does it with great
heart and great soul
and great consciousness.
They do a great job.
So I'm very happy to be
affiliated with them.
And then I also went to work
with "National Geographic
Traveler" as an editor at large.
I write a column
for their magazine
and I write a column
for their website.
And I love being affiliated
with "National Geographic."
It's one of the world's
great institutions.
Wherever I go, the
farthest-flung corner
of the world, when
I see someone and I
say I write for the
"National Geographic,"
they say, oh my God, I
love "National Geographic."
We have a stack like
that in our garage.
There's a lot of stacks of
"National Geographic"s all
around the world, apparently.
So I'm really
honored and thrilled
to work with those
two organizations.
And now I also work
with BBC Travel,
another fantastic global
brand and organization.
So I feel incredibly blessed.
I've been able to write and
travel, do the work that I
love, see the world that I
love, share me with the world.
And it's just been a really
incredibly special journey,
and it's still going.
So I thought I would be
just a couple of pieces,
short pieces from my book.
The book was a long time coming.
It was 40 years
coming, actually.
But it took me still about five
years of even intensely working
on the book to put it together.
I had about 700
articles to choose from.
And so there was a
lot of reading to do
and a lot of condensing to do.
And I ended up choosing the
articles that, to my mind,
reproduced two journeys.
There's always a journey
into the outer world,
but then in the
best travel stories
I think there's a journey
into the inner world
at the same time.
You talk about how a
place is affecting you.
And there's this kind
of back and forth.
So it's the record of two
contemporaneous journeys,
outside and inside.
And the stories in this
book try to do that.
Some of the stories
are very short--
750 words, the kind
of column length
that I've been
writing all my life.
The longest piece in
the book is 9,000 words.
The Cambodia story that
Laura kindly mentioned
is 7,000 words.
So there's a long-- there's
quite a wide spectrum there,
from about 500 words
to 9,000 words.
I like to think that
it's a great book
to take on the
road-- easy to read,
easy to read in an airplane,
quick chapters that
go by easily, slide
down easily, I hope.
I'm just going to read a
couple of those pieces.
So the first one I'm going
to read is called "Ryoan-ji
Reflections."
And it's about the Ryoan-ji
Rock Garden in Kyoto, Japan.
Has anybody been
there, by any chance?
OK, great.
Great.
And this was written
for a magazine
that I edited when I was
at the "Chronicle" that
was published four times a
year called "Great Escapes."
And every issue of "Great
Escapes" had a different theme.
The theme of this one
was sacred places.
So I begin in this essay
talking a little bit
about other sacred
places, and then I
get to Ryoan-ji Excuse me.
So this is "Ryoan-ji
Reflections."
"When I think of the sacred
places I have encountered
in my own travels, I recall
the Temple of Poseidon
on the cliff of Cape
[? Sunion ?] in Greece, where
I spent a wild night
huddled in my sleeping
bag among the moonlit
columns, surrounded
by tearing wind, the
crashing of waves,
and ghostly, godly dreams.
I think too of Bali, of the
lush, lovingly sculpted land
and the gentle people,
more profoundly imbued
with a sense of sanctity
of life as a holy gift
to be celebrated than
any other I have met.
But most vividly of all, I
think of a simple plot of sand
and rocks and moss in
Kyoto-- the rock garden
at Ryoan-ji Temple.
The guidebooks will tell you
that the rock garden was built
in the 15th century, probably
by a renowned Zen-influenced
artist named
[? Soami, ?] and that it
is considered a masterpiece of
the karesansui dry landscape
garden style.
It consists of 15 irregularly
shaped rocks of varying sizes,
some surrounded by moss,
arranged in a bed of white sand
that is raked every day.
A low earthen wall surrounds
the garden on three sides,
overhung by a narrow
beamed wooden roof.
On the fourth side,
wooden steps lead
to a wide wooden platform and
the main building of the temple
itself.
Beyond the wall are cedar,
pine, and cherry trees.
Such a description gives a
sense of the history and look
of the place, but to understand
its power, its pure presence,
you have to go there.
The first time I
visited Ryoan-ji,
I was overwhelmed, first by
the spareness of the site
and second by loudspeakers that
every 15 minutes squawked out
a recorded message about
the history and spirit
of the garden to the busloads
of obedient schoolchildren
and tourists who filed through.
But something held me there.
Morning passed to
afternoon, and still I
sat on the well-worn
platform, staring.
Kids in black caps, tiny
book-filled backpacks,
and black and white
school uniforms
passed by, studying me
while I studied the garden.
And adults in shiny
cameras in kimonos
clicked and clucked
and walked on.
Clouds came and went,
and the branches
beyond the garden bent,
straightened again, bent again.
I saw how the pebbly sand
had been meticulously raked
in circles around the
rocks and in straight lines
in the open areas, and
how those lines stopped
without a misplaced
pebble when they
touched the circular
patterns and then resumed
unchanged beyond them.
I saw how pockets of moss had
filled the pocks in the stones
and how the sand echoed
the sky, the moss echoed
the trees, the wall and
roof balanced the platform,
and the rocks seemed
to emanate a web
of intricate, tranquil
tension within the whole.
It was an exquisite enigma,
telling me something
I couldn't put words to.
And so it has remained.
I've seen Ryoan-ji in spring
when the cherry trees bloomed,
and in fall when their
branches were bare,
in winter, when snow
covered the moss,
and in summer when the cicadas
buzzed beyond the wall.
I've been there among
giggling teenagers
and gaping farmers, bemused
Westerners, and beatific monks.
By now, it has
become a part of me.
And still, it eludes me.
I love the place partly because
it is so emphatically not
a 10-minute tourist stop.
Its dimensions defy the camera.
I've never seen a true
picture of the place.
And its subtle simplicity
defies quick assimilation.
It makes you sit and
study, slow down,
and stare until you really
see it in its particularity
and in its whole,
simultaneously.
And yet, and here
the enigma expands.
You cannot see all of
Ryoan-ji at one time.
The rocks are so arranged
that you can see only 14
of the stones
wherever you stand.
You have to visualize,
imagine the final one.
How wonderful.
It is in this
sense that Ryoan-ji
is for me the
essential sacred place.
It is complete in itself.
But for you to
completely perceive it,
you have to transcend
the boundary
between inner and
outer, to travel
inward as well as outward,
to find and finish it
in your mind.
And the gigglers, the camera
clickers, and the squawking
loudspeakers are all, in
their exasperating reality,
part of this completion.
Beyond a great irony
of modern Japan,
loudspeakers instructing you
to appreciate the silence.
They embody a much
larger meaning.
You must embrace them all--
the monks and the moss
and the trees, the
schoolkids and the stones,
to really be there, to be whole.
Thanks.
That's Ryoan-ji.
So I hope that transported
you for a moment to Japan.
I'm going to read one other
story, one other little essay,
and then I'll just ask you
to tell me your questions
and we'll talk.
But I wanted to share this one.
It's about Stinson Beach Do
you all know Stinson Beach?
It's a special place,
and it's a place
I go back to all the time,
as you'll hear in this.
So this is called "A
Pilgrim at Stinson Beach."
"July 20, 2011, 11:30 AM.
I'm sitting at the southern
tip of Stinson Beach,
a glorious mile-long
stretch of sand that
borders the unincorporated,
population 650
hamlet of the same name in Marin
County, northern California.
Stinson Beach is a ragged,
flip-flops, bikinis and board
shorts kind of town.
And whether you're a Bay
Area visitor or resident,
it's a terrific place to stop.
A couple of inviting
restaurants face each other
across the sole street,
famed Highway 1, that
runs through town.
Both have sun-umbrelled
patios that
are intonations of heaven on a
balmy, blue sky day like today.
There are arts and
crafts galleries,
a quintessential little bit
of everything market, B&Bs,
and a beguiling bookstore
with a compact, ecumenical,
and eminently
Marin mix of books,
ranging from Zen treatises
and Native American history
and culture to mainstream
mysteries and fiction
and a proud selection of
work by local authors.
I love these riches, but
they're not why I come here.
Stinson Beach is about an hour's
winding drive from my house,
so it's not exactly an
on-a-whim destination for me.
Rather, it's a touchstone place
where I come together myself.
And today, I need gathering.
So here I am,
ensconced on a rock
beyond an outcrop
of massive boulders
that separates this thin slice
of sand from the main beach,
where a couple hundred people
are blissfully surfing,
strolling, and sunbathing.
I've been in this
spot for 20 minutes
and I haven't seen anyone,
except the teenage couple who
appeared holding hands,
literally just as I wrote--
I haven't seen anyone-- and
jumped when they saw me,
and now have
abruptly turned back.
And I like it that way.
In the 1980s and '90s when I
was the travel editor at the San
Francisco newspaper, I used
to make a pilgrimage here
every spring to write a column.
This was the place where
I gathered my thoughts,
looked back on the triumphs and
failures of the year passed,
and ahead to the New
Year's goals and dreams.
It's still a good place
to take stock of things.
The simplicity of
the scene strips away
the veneers of life, reduces
the distracting complexities.
Sea, rocks, sand,
sun-- that's it.
This spareness helps me, makes
me slow down and pay attention.
The roar and swash of the
waves echo in my ears.
The salty sea smell
fills my nose.
The sun warms like a hot
compress on my shoulders.
My toes wiggle into
the wet, cool sand.
The water white
froths in, spreads
into rippling fans
over the sand,
then rushes back
again and again.
A seagull web-walks through
the waves, leaps onto a rock,
scans the water for food.
It prances with oddly brittle
legs along the sand, flaps
to the top of a rock, and
imperiously surveys the waves.
A slick, six-foot seaweed
pod washes onto the beach.
A tiny insect scurries
over my keyboard.
A neon green bug lands
briefly on my screen.
I let the sea wash over me,
let the waves fill my head
and lungs, lose myself to this
inconceivably old and ageless
place.
I think, this is the same scene
I witnessed two decades ago,
quite possibly the
same rock I sat
on then, scribbling in my
journal as I tap into my laptop
now.
And if I come back in 20
years, it will almost certainly
be the same still.
But of course, much has
changed in those two decades.
My children have
grown up and moved on.
My dad and other loved
ones have passed away.
New jobs, new places,
new books, old dreams.
And suddenly, these
words flow into my brain.
Where does it all come together?
What does it mean?
The sea swashing ceaselessly
scrubs the mind clean.
I palm the rough, sandy surface
of the boulder to my left,
warmed by the sun, cradling sand
in its pocks in green ridges
of moss in its cracks, etched
by wind, wave, and rain.
Wisps like smoke from a
seaborne fire drift around me.
And on the horizon, a
bank of gray-blue fog
gathers, curling at
the top so that it
looks like a frozen tidal wave.
I think of the
tsunami in Sendai,
where my daughter
traveled recently and saw
the destruction
with her own eyes,
with a local man who was guiding
her broke down and cried.
All those uprooted lives--
where does it come together?
What does it mean?
The waves push collecting
pebbles onto the shore, fan,
recede.
The seagull flaps away
unsatisfied, searching.
Life is precarious,
uncertain, brief.
There is a precious
precariousness
at the heart of all things.
The sea swashing ceaselessly
scrubs the mind clean.
The waves roar, splash in,
getting a little closer now.
The tide is coming in.
The blue pebble we inhabit is
turning in the celestial sea.
Where does it come together?
What does it mean?
Focus.
Enjoy the moment
while you have it.
Enjoy your loved ones
while you have them.
Recognize the gifts
the world gives you.
Inhale the sea.
Sink your toes into the sand.
Let the ocean roar
silence your mind.
Then take this simple
scene home with you--
sun, sand, rocks, sea.
The sea swashing ceaselessly
scrubs the mind clean.
What it all comes
down to, I think,
is the relationships you forge,
the experiences you embrace,
the lessons you bestow,
the ideals you seed,
the love you live and leave.
Dedicate yourself to
creating something of value
with your days,
something that will last.
The sea swashing ceaselessly
scrubs the mind clean.
Where does it come together?
What does it mean?
Sun, sand, rocks, sea--
a Stinson Beach clarity.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
That's very kind.
Thank you very, very much.
So I'd love to open the
floor to your questions.
How to become a travel
writer, the best
place to go in the world.
AUDIENCE: So how do you balance
the actual writing process
with the traveling?
Do you write while
you're traveling?
How you stay in the moment
there and then come up
with these great
pieces at the end?
DON GEORGE: Thank you.
So it's an ongoing process.
I take copious
notes on the road.
I have a little notebook that
I carry it with me all the time
that-- I actually
have it right here.
I literally carry it
with me all the time.
It's this wonderful notebook.
And in case I forget
what it is, it helpfully
says Notebook on the cover.
So that's good.
I got this in Japan
when I lived there,
and I've loved them and
carried them ever since.
This is number 14 that I'm on.
So I carry these
with me, and I always
try to make time to sit
somewhere for an hour
and write about what's
happening around me.
And then I also take notes.
Frequently on the
road, I'll just
jot down little quick notes--
"blue poppies, gray field,"
something like that, just to
remind me where I've been.
And I use my phone a lot.
I'll talk into my
phone to record
my impressions of a place.
And I use my camera
a lot, my phone.
I use my phone a lot
again as my camera
to take photos so the limited
storage capacity of my brain
doesn't have to remember
what things looked like.
I can do that with a photo.
So I'm constantly
doing that on the road.
And the other thing that I'm
doing on the road constantly
is trying to figure
out what the story is.
I'm in a place and I'm thinking,
what am I going to write about?
What am I going to write about?
That voice becomes
annoying but essential.
And I try my best
to embrace the place
and give myself
to it as fully as
possible and at the same
time to figure out what
the essence of the place is.
What's the story for me?
What's the connection?
What's the passion point between
me and a place that might
develop into a bigger story?
And I just do that over
and over and over again.
Been doing it for 40 years now.
And one of these decades,
I'm going to get it down.
And that turns out to be a
very fruitful coalescence
that I again can bring back
home and write the story.
More in contemplative
reflection at home--
I really do the writing writing.
But I have a lot of massive
body of notes to deal with
to help me with that.
AUDIENCE: You been
to so many places,
and I wonder where
you going next,
and how do you
select those places?
DON GEORGE: Great question.
Well, I'm literally
going next to Japan,
which is not new to me,
but it's always new anyway.
I'm actually going there
on March 26th with Kuniko.
And we're going to
go to Kyoto and then
to the island of Shikoku,
where Kuniko is from.
And it's partly pleasure
and partly work for me.
I actually lead to
a small tour group
for Geographic Expeditions,
a group of eight people.
So we're going to go
to Kyoto and Shikoku.
I try to show them the wonders
of Japan through my eyes,
and they end up
showing me the wonders
of Japan through their
eyes, which is really nice.
And so that's my next trip.
How I decide where
to go is partly--
it's a mixture of the
outside world coming to me
and me going to
the outside world.
A good example is I was invited
to go to the Melbourne Writer's
Festival.
And I went there, and then the
Singapore Writer's Festival
invited me to go there,
so I went to Singapore.
Or I knew I was going
to go to Singapore,
and I realize that Singapore
was very close to Cambodia.
And I'd always wanted
to go to Angkor Wat,
ever since I'd
been a child and I
think I'd seen a
photo of Angkor Wat
in "National Geographic,"
probably-- one of those stacks
in the garage.
And I realized I could do that.
From Singapore, it
was a quick flight,
so I made my quick flight.
I did that myself,
and I ended up
writing about it for the BBC
Travel, a column that I edit.
So Melbourne and
Singapore were invitations
from the outside world that
enticed me to go there.
And I ended up writing some
things about that as well.
And then the trip I
really wanted to make
was the one to Cambodia, which
I just put together myself
because it was so close.
And I figured something magical
would happen in Cambodia,
and it definitely,
definitely did.
And it was not what
I expected at all.
And you can read
about in the book.
It's the last story in the
book is my trip to Cambodia
and how incredibly
overwhelmed I was, and moved
beyond expression almost by
my encounters with the people
there.
And I got out into
the jungle, and there
was a temple in the jungle, and
I had my little Indiana Jones
moment.
I was really, really a moving,
profoundly life-changing trip.
So it's that kind of a balance
of the world coming to me
and me going out to
the world, I think.
Did that answer the question?
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering how can you
disconnect yourself or
connect to the places you
travel when there's so
much technology around you?
Because when I travel,
it's so hard for me
to stay away from your phone.
I try to keep away
from it, but I'm always
checking it for maybe
translations or directions.
And then I check email.
And it's just a disaster
every single time
I try to just let myself
go and enjoy the moment.
DON GEORGE: Yes.
You must work for a tech
company or something.
Yeah, it's a huge distraction.
It's really an incredibly
huge distraction.
And so I make a very,
very conscious effort.
It's the equivalent of, when I
was the spokesperson for Lonely
Planet, one of the
things I always
would say is that we at Lonely
Planet who publish guidebooks
would like you to leave your
guidebook behind at least
one day of your journey
and go out and get lost.
Because that's going to
show you a different place.
We're happy that
with our guidebooks
we can help you
understand a place better,
but you will understand
in a different way
if you leave your guidebook
in your hotel room
and go out and get lost.
So please do that.
And I feel the same way about
all the wonderful technology
that we have at our fingertips.
I leave that in my hotel
room at least once, one day.
And I just wander out and
get lost and immerse myself
in the place.
And I tell myself that
I'm on assignment.
And that sort of
liberates me from having
to update my Facebook or
answer email or tweets.
I say, you know, you're here.
Be here.
Every time you post on
Facebook it's a bit of a-- it
takes you away for a
second from being here.
And so I try to have moments,
protracted moments of time
when I'm without any
technology in my life at all,
except maybe my camera
and my phone as my camera.
And so I immerse
myself in the place.
And for me, that kind
of immersive travel
is really hugely important.
Part of the wonder
of my Cambodia trip
was I spent a
homestay in a place
called Banteay Chmara
where there was no Wi-Fi.
So when I first got there, I
said, and how's the Wi-Fi here?
And my host said,
there is no Wi-Fi here.
Oh-- and I went, oh my
God, what am I going to do?
And then I thought,
that's wonderful.
I have three days without Wi-Fi.
I can just kind
of really be here.
And it was.
It was a great gift.
And so I think you have to
give yourself that gift.
And it is a gift.
You get more out of
the place, I think,
when you're not
constantly thinking,
how could I tweet about this or
how could I Facebook about this
or how could I send
an email about this.
Sometimes it's good
to just be there--
be there, be there, be there.
And I really strongly
recommend that.
Because the technology's there,
and you'll always have it.
But you'll only be in
Cambodia for a few days
or a few precious moments,
so make the most of it.
Did that make
sense as an answer?
So on your next trip I want you
to do that and send me an email
and let me know how it went.
AUDIENCE: What advice would
you give her getting published,
for someone just starting out?
There seems to be an overload
of information on where
to send things, who to--
DON GEORGE: Yeah.
There is an overload
of information.
I would be remiss
if I didn't mention
my book, "Lonely Planet's
Guide to Travel Writing."
It's a book about how to
be a travel writer, so it
has a lot of information,
I hope good information,
about how to get published.
But I think, as
you know, there's
the self-publishing route.
You can have a blog.
You can have your own website.
You can publish
yourself that way.
And that's great
and fine, and you
can grow a presence
and a platform
and reach people that way.
The more traditional,
conventional route
is getting published
in newspapers
and magazines and websites.
And I think the secret to doing
that is to target one or two
or three places that you really,
really want to appear in,
and just get to know
them intimately.
So what I say in my
book is, you should
become the editor of the place
that you want to get published.
In your head, you
should understand
exactly why each story is there,
what its role in the picture
puzzle.
Every editor has a picture
puzzle of their publication
in their brain.
And if you can figure out
what that puzzle looks like
and why that story's there
and why that story's
there, then you
can come up with a story that
fits that picture puzzle.
And then you could write a query
letter to the editor saying,
I have this great story about
Portugal that I want to do,
and it's about a homestay.
And I've noticed you
enjoy publishing stories
on homestays, and I think
this would fit perfectly
with your editorial mission.
And that's the way
to do it, basically.
Become the editor
of the publication
you want to get
into, figure out how
your story fits into
that picture puzzle,
and then send it off.
The other way that
I should say too
is if you want to
write for magazines,
the tried and true
route is to write
little tiny, 200-word
pieces that are
in the front of the magazine.
That's what most people do--
the hot new hotel just opened
in San Francisco, and you do
four or five or six of those
and you develop a
rapport with an editor.
And then the editor says,
why don't you send me
a pitch for a larger story?
We'd like to move you into the
middle of the magazine now.
So that's another great way.
And I know a number of
writers who started out
that way, writing those
250-word little stories
and they develop
that relationship,
and then suddenly they're in the
middle of the magazine writing
long stories.
I hope it works.
AUDIENCE: My
question is, as we've
seen a lot of political
and economic shifts
in the world over
the last few decades,
and you being a travel writer,
having doing this for 40 years
or so, have those
shifts affected
the way you observe a
place when you go there
or your writings in any way?
DON GEORGE: Yes,
that's a big question.
It's a great
question-- definitely.
All those shifts really
affect me as a human being,
as a traveler.
Some places that I went 40
years ago, you can't go to now.
Other places that you
couldn't go 40 years ago,
you can go to now.
I find myself in a
place like Dubrovnic.
When I was in Dubrovnic--
the siege of Dubrovnic
had just happened a
couple of years earlier.
And so you could literally see
the damage done by the bombs
all around you.
And I remember walking along the
walls that go around Dubrovnic
and looking at a stretch
of rooftops, roof tiles.
And there were fractured,
scattered roof tiles.
And then right next to them,
there were the new roof tiles.
And that seemed like
such a poignant metaphor
for me of what had
happened there,
both the destruction
and the rebuilding.
And I realized that
I, as a tourist,
putting dollars into that or
putting money into that economy
was part of that new roof tile.
I was part of the
reconstruction of the place.
And I think that that's a
huge part of travel for me,
is what we do to
the places we go to.
We could do bad or
we can do great.
And as a traveler
going to a place that's
just come out of a period of
divisive war, you do great.
And I was happy in
Dubrovnic that I could
be a part of that process.
And again, Mostar
when I was there,
you could see the
traces of bullet holes
in all the buildings.
I went to the cemetery
and the cemetery
there all these
fresh plots, people
who died in the recent war.
And I just thought, thank
God that I'm here now,
that I can bear witness to
the rebirth of this place,
that I can help that
rebirth, and that I
can tell the world about,
it's safe to come here now.
Please come.
Bring your money with you.
Help build this wonderful,
beautiful, cultural center
back into the great
place it used to be.
So that world is
constantly changing.
There's always challenges.
There's places you can't
go and places you can go.
And I find that
my message always
is affected by whatever has
happened in the place where
I've just been.
And Cambodia was
an amazing example.
This terrible, tragic civil
war that they had with Pol Pot.
And to see the hope
and resilience,
to see the opening
children's eyes
was incredibly moving to me.
They had these bright, piercing,
wonderfully bright eyes.
And I just thought, there's
the future right there.
And how extraordinary it is,
one, that the adults around me
survived what they
survived and lived to tell.
But how wonderful that the
children, the next generation,
are full of hope and
enthusiasm and energy
and they're going to make
the world a better place,
not just their country
a better place.
They'll make the
world a better place.
And so my whole life has
been this wonderful kind
of interchange between
the world and me
and what's going on
politically and economically.
And travel makes such a huge,
profound difference in that
and really, really helps make
the world a better place.
And I think that as travelers,
we connect with people.
We meet people.
We understand that
there is no other.
Before we go somewhere,
it's an other.
And then we go there
and there is no other.
They're like us.
We're all the same.
We're all in this
big boat together.
And I think that travel, more
than anything else probably
paves the road for peace and
understanding and connection
among people.
And that's why I've become a
travel evangelist, I feel like.
This is my pulpit,
and I talk about,
get out there and travel,
because it changes
the world for the better.
You become an agent
of great change.
So that was a very long-winded
answer to your question,
but I hope that made sense.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: When you
live in California,
it seems that everything
is recycled, organic,
and every other person is
either starting a charity
or supporting one passionately.
But then you open up
the news or a newspaper
and you read about how
much we're consuming
and how bad everything
is, and everything
is being destroyed, basically.
So with your years
of experience,
have you noticed
any kind of patterns
or what do you see when
you're out there, basically?
DON GEORGE: That's
a great question.
I think that the world
is-- evolution, I think,
is workin- very, very,
very, very slowly.
But the world is much more
conscious ecologically
now than it was 40 years
ago, when I started out.
Still, there's such
a long way to go.
But recycling has taken
root in places where there
was no recycling 40 years ago.
The whole notion, for example,
of not using plastic bottles
has started to catch
on more and more.
There's still such
a long way to go,
but people have stopped-- people
are more aware of not using
plastic as being a good thing.
Environmental
stewardship-- not just
leaving your trash behind when
you go out on a mountain trail,
but making sure that
you pack out everything
that you packed in.
Those kinds of
principles and practices
are definitely spreading.
And it's remarkably slow,
but it's still spreading
in the right direction.
So I'm thrilled about that.
On the other hand,
there are things
that are really sobering.
We were talking earlier
about Mount Kilimanjaro.
I climbed Kilimanjaro in 1976.
And there was still
a lot of snow.
There was a really substantial
amount of snow up there.
And recent photographs
that I've seen,
there's very little
snow left there.
And that's sobering, scary.
We're unleashing forces which we
know nothing about, basically,
I think.
So that gives me a
certain amount of despair.
But I counter that despair
by doing everything
that I can to make the
world a better place
and encouraging the people I
come into contact with to do
the same thing and to be
environmentally conscious
and do the right thing by the
planet and by the environment.
And I do think that message
is definitely spreading.
And it's easy to get
despairing, but I feel hopeful.
In 40, years I feel the
planet's on the right track.
Things are getting better and
better in a lot of places.
People are more and
more enlightened.
They're more and more
aware of the effect
that they have on the
world around them.
And while there's an
extraordinarily long way to go,
at least we're in
the right direction.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much
for coming today and sharing
your wonderful stories.
I The first thing I want to say
is, I would argue that you did
become a poet
through your stories.
They're wonderful.
DON GEORGE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Secondly,
I'd like to know,
would you consider
returning to Google
and perhaps doing a brown
bag or workshop with us
and share some of the
awarenesses and knowledge
you've gained over your trips?
DON GEORGE: Thank you.
I'm honored.
If Google would like
me to come back,
I would love to come back.
I would totally
love to come back.
[APPLAUSE]
That's wonderful.
That's the best question yet.
Well, I just want
to take a moment
to say thank you so very,
very much for being here
and for listening
so wonderfully,
attentively, and for allowing
me to share my stories with you.
And if I can come back
and share some more,
I really would love to.
But this has been a
great blessing for me,
so thank you very, very much.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]